[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 28 juin bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 c'est le
tour d'horizon de l'actualité locale et
régionale tout de suite les titres de
cette édition un rassemblement sous un
même mouvement celui des amoureux de la
france hier soir au chesnay nicolas
dupont aignan et jean frédéric poisson
obtenu une réunion publique commune
devant 400 personnes avec d'autres élus
le souhaitent à faire front commun face
à la politique gouvernementale en vue
des prochaines européennes les yvelines
et les hauts-de-seine encore plus proche
ce matin à nanterre les deux
collectivités ont annoncé est la mise en
commun de services et compétences dont
la gestion des collèges une nouvelle
étape dans la perspective de fusion des
deux départements entamé depuis 2016 et
puis la mesure entrera en vigueur ce
dimanche les routes à double sens en
séparateur central seront limités à 80
kilomètres heure contre 90 jusqu'à
présent près de 600 km dax concernées
dans le département ou conducteurs et
associations ne sont pas convaincus du
bien fondé de la mesure vous l'entendrez
dans ce journal
on prend tout de suite la direction du
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on va
retrouver notre monsieur sport de la
rédaction c'est michael et demi d'euros
bonsoir alors le à chennai open de
france mickaël a débuté aujourd'hui
c'est jusqu'à à dimanche
40000 spectateurs attendus et un plateau
très relevé pour cette édition oui
grégory un plateau très relevé il y a le
numéro deux mondiale justin thomas ce
qui est présent ici pour la première
fois au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines qui est également le numéro
un français alexander levy qui est
présent il ya les deux espagnols john
rabe et sergio garcia qui sont également
des têtes d'affiché vraiment du circuit
yas tommy fleetwood bien sûr l'anglais
qui a gagné ici aussi l'an passé et à
mes côtés il ya également le coach de
raphaël jacquelin raphaël jacquelin
justement comment se porte-t-il c'est
aussi une tête d'affiché parmi les
français sur cet open de france
il a une difficulté 7 et un triple
boguey au 10e j'ai pas vu comme insisté
passion 10 parce que j'étais déçu après
le match
elle entraîne jour de 15 derrière vous
dans une +5 total donc c'est pas bon
mais c'est pas encore complètement mort
pour lequel parce que c'est le parcours
est difficile je pense que d'être assez
au domaine au moins + 4 ou 5
donc s'il fait une bonne journée demain
matin à 8h30 encore avec un peu moins de
20 le matin et un peu moins de vent le
parcours là c'est ta timidité très très
difficiles avec beaucoup de vent lors le
saint patron pascal bride des plantes
mais c'est très très fort avec un bref
importants dons servent rêve et charges
je serais curieux de savoir ce que le
capitaine de la ryder cup qui joue avec
raphaël aujourd'hui et voilà sa balle
dit du parcours à la fin de ces deux
tours est-ce qui va le laisser comme ça
pour la ryder cup
qu'est-ce qu'il va le rendre un peu plus
saine je sais pas parce qu'elle est très
très difficile
et qu'est ce que vous avez pensé les
têtes d'affiché justement sur leur
partie du matin je crois qu alexander
levy a été un petit peu en difficulté
sur les premiers au premier au premier
il a commencé au 10 par un triple bogey
alors qu'il avait une s'abattre sur le
carreau et il a fait une erreur au
deuxième coup il a fait un mauvais
chipsets assez mal à enclencher a pris
l'habit l'énergie il a fait un bond de
nombre de bord dit fini par plus de donc
tout va bien pour lui
après c'est vrai que c'est certainement
pour lui avec justin thomas c'est au
wifi pour beaucoup de pression mais pas
de pression au sens où il a peur de
jouer mais quand même beaucoup d'émotion
au départ du 1 et donc voilà après il a
sauvé la journée je crois qui est une
belle performance en commençant par un
tripot 10 et après il fait un autre de
nos classes dont il fait quand même une
belle journée je trouve au niveau du sol
peut être catastrophique il a sauvé bien
il ya plusieurs milliers de personnes
qui sont ici
vous disiez alexandre lévy a été très
suivi a énormément de personnes l'ont
suivi sur sa partie est ce que ça a pu
jouer peut-être sur cette entrée on va
dire timorés dans la compétition a mis
un peu de pression il est attendu des
numéros français c'est à peu près le
seul français qui peut faire la ryder
cup et joue avec justin thomas quelqu'un
qui encore plus jeune que lui qui va
être certainement certitude même de
l'équipe américaine de ryder cup
tout me fit tourner les français ont
beau temps quand un produit dont je
pense pas que il a réussi le premier
coup ou non ce n'est pas un mauvais
premier coup mais je pense que cela met
un peu de pression
j'ai l'impression que sir alex a fait
une partie avec on va dire des joueurs
normaux du tour européen
peut-être qu'il aurait ce corps est
beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui parce que son
jeu
beaucoup mieux que le plus d'eau je
pense a pas aidés et quand vous avez
trouvé justin thomassin celui dont tout
le monde parlait ici au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
fantastique qui est un chien qui a un
petit jeu extraordinaire qui s'aiment
pas dire il faut dessus venir voir il ya
également un joueur qui a un petit peu
déçu c'est tommy fleetwood le vainqueur
de l'an passé
il a notamment mis sa balle en dehors du
parcours qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensez vous j'ai pas vu le coup j'ai pas
vu le coup c'est assez rare dans la
partie assez rare parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est un swing très très
solide maintenant c'est un parcours très
très difficile qui met beaucoup de
pression c'est à dire on perd la balle
son premier coup on peut perdre la balle
sion deuxième on peut mettre des
panneaux et donc au bout d'un moment là
la confiance et le swing même si c'est
une belle mécanique vous commencé à se
détériorer ça peut arriver aux meilleurs
de 29 avril ça prouve la difficulté du
terrain à commencer de sa cause du
terrain tommy fit plus de 1000 mah leurs
limites et je pense que si on lui
demande si vous avez l'occasion de
demander je pense qu'il se rappelle même
pas là d'un enfant de la mine valeurs
limites calme axa remonte à longtemps
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
matchs finalement de ryder cup on peut
le dire alexander levy tommy fleetwood
contre justin thomass c'est la ryder cup
a commencé ici à saint quentin en
yvelines
je crois d'ailleurs que une
paradoxalement si je pense que si on
prend leur carte à masquer avec
s'organise parce que alex fait plus deux
avec un triple double mais chacun cinq
ou six birdies et je pense qu'à masquer
avec sandler organise symtoma sur cette
jeunesse donc je disais tout à l'heure
il ya énormément monde ici un saint
quentin en yvelines
est-ce que vous inciter les gens à venir
encore plus nombreux pour venir voir les
justin thomas si alexander levy ou les
rappels jacquelin on ne sait jamais il
peut passer le cut
bien sûr tout le monde tout ce qu'ils
vont être entreprises 4 et +6 ce soit un
jour le matin avec un petit peu moins de
vingt n'auront pas besoin de faire un
exploit pour jouer ce week-end donc
c'est vraiment ouvert
effectivement qui vous venir en plus
ternes et je trouve que pour la
préparation la ryder cup
ils ont coupé les hautes herbes et on
sait qu'on doit encore mieux de loin
et ça me coûte plus agréable à suivre ce
parcours qui était déjà fantastique a su
merci beaucoup merci d'être et d'avoir
quitté la partie de raphaël jacquelin
pour venir avec nous en duplex sur tv 78
merci merci beaucoup
et merci à vous si l'open de france
l'open de france de golf c'est jusqu'à
ce dimanche sur les greens du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
merci michael à vous notre monsieur
sport notre monsieur golf va falloir s'y
habituer avec cette ryder cup qui arrive
et vous étiez donc depuis l'open de
france de golf au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines avec nicolas landry
aux moyens techniques on parlera
d'ailleurs un de sport d'ici la fin de
cette édition avec une autre grande
compétition qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui
c'est les championnats de france de
cyclisme sur route
l actualité est également sociale en ce
dernier jour de mouvement en pointillés
des cheminot à la sncf une grève
interprofessionnelle se tenait également
aujourd'hui une mobilisation à l'appel
de fo et de la cgt
une première depuis 2016 pour défendre
le modèle je cite social et républicain
avant le départ pour le cortège parisien
une cinquantaine de militants de la cgt
60,18 s'est réuni à la mi journée devant
la préfecture des yvelines des
rassemblements se sont tenus également à
saint-cyr-l'ecole devant la mairie 130
agents de la commune étaient présents
d'après le syndicat en politique aussi
se rassemblent contre la politique d'
emmanuel macron hier soir au chesnay
jean frédéric poisson et nicolas dupont
aignan se sont rassemblés une même
bannière celle des amoureux de la france
est la réunion publique a attiré plus de
400 personnes nicolas kirillovitch et
mélanie poquet nous sommes en france
faire front emmanuel matrix ou douce les
mêmes d'asnières hier soir jean frédéric
poisson et nicolas dupont aignan parler
d'une même voix celle du collectif les
amoureux de la france
lancé en octobre 2017 je maintiens que
le projet du président emmanuel macron
est le plus dangereux qu'on est connu
pour le pays depuis longtemps il promet
la souveraineté il promet la société
communautariste contre une culture qui
est la culture française et qui doit
continuer à irriguer notre pays je pense
que les français recommence avoir
conscience que macro est en train de
vendre la france par morceau de mener à
la misère sociale et surtout de aussi de
laisser une immigration sans fin
coloniser le pays j'employais ce terme
violent pour faire réagir mes
compatriotes
ils veulent réagir face à une situation
qu'ils estiment urgente et appelle à un
rassemblement de toutes les droites en
présence de jacques mignard mais avait
l'air de maisons laffitte christine
boutin de membres de la manif pour tous
et d'anciens élus du front national la
réunion a rassemblé près de 2 400
personnes
il faut rassembler
au delà des clivages même gérer il faut
rassembler la droite des gens qui ont
les mêmes la même façon penser que
debout la france qu'il faut qu' il ya
différentes parties qui propose
différentes choses s'il ya un parti
unique c'est un plus aucune la politique
n'a plus aucune valeur
je crois que la droite n'a pas intérêt à
se diviser
l'initiative prise par nicolas dupont
aignan va certainement dans la bonne
direction
c'est génial c'est ce qu'il faut
autrement on s'en sortira pas les
amoureux de la france présenteront un
programme commun pour les élections
européennes de mai 2019
un autre rapprochement celui des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine qui
poursuivent la fusion de leurs services
les présidents des deux collectivités
pierre bédier et patrick devedjian ont
annoncé ce jeudi à nanterre la mise en
commun de plusieurs compétences
notamment est la gestion des collèges
une manière de maintenir cette dynamique
de rapprochement les détails avec
nicolas landry et patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est l'acte 2 du rapprochement entre
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine de
nouvelles compétences seront
prochainement mutualiser la commande
publique et l'éducation avec notamment
une gestion interdépartementale des 214
collège des départements bien entendu il
n'y aura pas de fermeture du collège
bien entendu il n'y aura pas moins
d'effectifs dans les collèges cette
administration centrale ce qu'on appelle
l'administration centrale que la
convergence se fera nous pensons là
aussi que leurs rassemblements de c2c
direction pourra nous permettre de faire
mieux avec moins
cet objectif a motivé la création de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental en février 2016
actuellement 45% des compétences
départementales sont communes et les
deux collectivités s'inspire l'une de
l'autre
nous avons constaté que le
services d'eveline fonctionnait bien
qu'il donnait de bons résultats tous les
cas que c'était mieux que ce que nous
faisons donc via pas de problème nous
adhérons à activity en unifiant ses
nouveaux services les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine veulent rendre
irréversible leur fusion même si le
gouvernement n'a pas rendu d'avis
concernant la création d'une seule
collectivité annoncé en janvier la
mesure entrera en vigueur ce dimanche en
france le passage de 90 à 80 km heure
sur les routes à double sens en
séparateur central et dans les yvelines
un peu moins de 600 kilomètres de routes
sont concernés les services techniques
ont déjà changé les panneaux sur cèze
sur certains secteurs ils restent bâchés
pour le moment pour ne pas perturber les
conducteurs des automobilistes pas
forcément convaincu du bien fondé de la
mesure reportage de patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas kirillovitch
2 90 à 80 km/heure le changement s'opère
seulement quelques secondes pour ces
agents de la voirie
donc on fait faut juste de dévisser au
niveau des brides donc à quatre vis à
desserrer et remettre quatre vis pour
remettre le 80 donc c'est assez rapide
comme comme opération une opération
rapide en bord de route il y a une
dizaine de panneaux a changé dans ce
secteur cent cinq au total dans le
département des yvelines
d'ici le 1er juillet près de 600
kilomètres de routes passeront à 80
km/heure une mesure pour la sécurité
routière pour le gouvernement qui espère
sauver 300 à 400 vies par an mais une
mesure qui fait débat auprès de
l'opinion dans la vallée de chevreuse
connu pour ses routes accidentées comme
la départementale 906 l'abaissement de
la vitesse c'est diversement accueillie
par les habitants des zones dangereuses
que 80 c'est très bien et d'autres 90
bon effectivement maintenant ça dépend
du civisme chacun respecte ne respecte
pas et je crois que c'est une vraie
mesure c'est mathématique ça ne se
défend pas donc tout à fait pour pour
chevreuse et les alentours wee cc c'est
bien mais
moi je pense que oui c'est un peu quand
même exagéré pour c'est de la com et
c'est pour nous pomper encore du fric
comme d'habitude la crainte des amendes
et des flashs principaux arguments
avancés par les opposants à cette
réduction de la vitesse
les gendarmes se veulent pourtant
rassurants dans un premier temps ils
promettent d'être clément avec les
contrevenants ce que nous allons faire
c'est accompagner le changement de cette
nombre et je vais demander au gendarme
doit c'est que t'as routière des
yvelines de faire preuve de pédagogie
pour expliquer les raisons de son
changement le 1er juillet les jours qui
suivront nous serons sur les routes a
réalisé des contrôles routiers mais ne
seront prioritairement axé sur le
contrôle des grands excès de vitesse les
plus dangereux c'est bien ça notre
mission en 2017 dans les yvelines 48
personnes sont décédées sur les routes
du département 17 d'entre elles sur les
axes concernés par la réforme et depuis
l'annnonce des grandes mesures pour la
sécurité routière en janvier
associations d'automobilistes et de
motards sont vent debout notamment
contre le passage à 80 km heure et des
recours ont été déposés auprès du
conseil constitutionnel la fédération
des motards en colère des yvelines elle
participera à la manifestation ce samedi
à vincennes un départ groupé est prévu
de louveciennes écouter le coordinateur
départemental de la ffmc 78 elles
assimilent agit de la roue à de
perpétuelles délinquants et elle est
d'usagé des vrais enjeux de sécurité
routière fait 10 milliards ont pas
toutes nos raids
mais globalement les grands oubliés de
ces mesures sur la prévention et les
infrastructures inquiets pour nous sont
un combat important dans la mesure où
nous sommes des usagers motards
vulnérables et que la prévention des
usagers est faible et d'autres usagers
et apportant ainsi que l'entretien du
réseau routier est viré secondaire qui
est concernée par ces mesures
on est tous pour la diminution du nombre
de tués sur les routes mais je ne pense
pas que le gouvernement prenne le bon
côté des choses pour résoudre
ce problème la ffmc 78 qui participera
également une manifestation ce dimanche
à rouen
juste après ce journal le 7-8 débat
abordera d'ailleurs la question de la
grogne face à la baisse de la vitesse à
80 km/heure après une semaine de
fermeture pour cause de vidange le
centre aquatique de montigny le
bretonneux va rouvrir ses portes samedi
matin l occasion pendant cette pause de
faire quelques changements de pièces
dans la partie machinerie en début
d'année la piscine avait été fermée
durant quatre semaines pour d'importants
travaux d'entretien changement de sols
et de murs dans les sanitaires ou encore
changement du contrôle d'accès est des
travaux qui ont coûté quatre cent mille
euros un montant important mais
nécessaires pour accueillir au mieux les
utilisateurs propos recueillis par
aurélie ronces on a aujourd'hui un outil
qui est bientôt avoir 16 ans ce qui est
par rapport à l'état aujourd'hui de
notre piscine on est plutôt satisfait
mais ça veut dire que l'on passe aussi
par un entretien permanent de
à la fois extérieur donc ce que voit nos
utilisateurs mais à la fois aussi au
niveau interne donc la partie la partie
je dirais que sous marine que tous les
gens ne voient pas forcément mais qui
est très importante et je dirais même
presque le plus important
ce dispositif permet à des jeunes de 16
à 25 ans de s'engager dans une structure
au service de l'intérêt général et ce
pour une durée de 6 à 12 mois
le service civique était au coeur d'une
réunion ce jeudi matin à la préfecture
des yvelines les volontaires ils étaient
invités à partager leurs expériences
camille lambert était sur place depuis
février
ramata et volontaire auprès d'une
association elle donne des cours de
français à des étrangers pour faciliter
leur intégration
cette année comme plus de 850 yves
binois âgés de 16 à 25 ans elle est
engagée dans un service civique
quand jd mon petit frère à faire ses
devoirs j'étais quelqu'un qui s'en
allèrent vais trop vite donc avec eux
j'ai j'ai petit à petit j'ai appris à
canaliser éviter de m'énerver vite du
coup j'ai pris confiance en moi je me
suis dis papa besoin de ce que de
s'inquiéter donc ça va venir petit à
petit je fais de la médiation numérique
et j'essaie de réparer ce qu'on appelle
la fracture numérique
l'exclusion numérique c'est une mission
très utile je me sens très utile dans ce
que je fais solidarité éducation
environnement culture ou sport un
engagement au service de l'intérêt
général auprès de collectivités
territoriales d'établissements publics
ou services de l'état pour une durée de
6 à 12 mois
indemnisés 580 euros par mois le service
civique est un premier pas dans la
socialisation plus tard ici luxe et par
l'emploi c'est pas un stage mais c'est
vrai qu'on est à la limite du travail
puisque le jeune considère que ma il va
travailler en fait le matin et doit se
lever il travaille dans une équipe il un
cadre et un chef qui lui donne des
ordres
et ça ça était bien dit tout à l'heure
par certains jeunes et du coup c'est
vraiment un tremplin pour moi pour
l'insertion sociale au sens général donc
à la fois aux professionnels mais aussi
social mis en place en 2010 par le
gouvernement le service civique a déjà
permis à plus de 3000 jeunes yvelinois
de participer à une mission
ce dimanche ils devraient être près d'un
million et
me de téléspectateurs à suivre l'épreuve
phare de la compétition les championnats
de france de cyclisme sur route ont
débuté aujourd'hui à mantes la jolie
une première pour la commune yvelinoise
et pour ce premier jour les femmes
notamment étaient à l'honneur avec le
contre contre-la-montre par dons
individuels élites et espoirs
audrey cordon ragot a conservé son titre
chez les élites ça c'est le quatrième de
sa carrière
on écoute sa réaction au micro de maxime
le maine pour le conseil départemental
des civils et ben c'était un très beau
parcours vraiment là parcours de
spécialistes du chrono donc c'est vrai
que quand je les ai découverts j'étais
pas déçu je savais que c'est un parcours
qui me convient assez bien avec dédé
long bout droit on peut vraiment
s'exprimer avec avec beaucoup de
puissance et c'est ce qui me caractérise
donc c'était vraiment parfait pour moi
donc très satisfaite en plus un soleil
magnifique peut-être un petit peu trop
chaud pour un contre-la-montre mais non
c'était vraiment super et un public
génial également c'est vrai qu'on est un
petit peu surpris de découvrir en région
parisienne finalement une campagne qui
ressemble un petit peu à la bretagne
c'est vallonné avec avec une agriculture
qui a l'air qui allaient intensive aussi
par ici et non se retrouver un petit peu
du coup comme à la maison
et pour tout savoir de ces championnats
de france qui se déroule jusqu'à
dimanche à mantes-la-jolie je vous
propose dorénavant d'écouter cet
entretien michael almy doro recevait
dans son être dernier 7,8 sport un
représentant de la fédération française
de cyclisme
alors pour quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas
du tout ces championnats de france
est ce qu'on peut nous le présentait
alors championne de france en cyclisme
au lieu de six en compétition
d'envergure
c'est une compétition d'envergure pour
la simple et bonne raison qu'elle est
une semaine avant le tour de france est
souvent en fait celui qui champion de
france on va là on va voir son maillot
bleu-blanc-rouge sur le tour de france
et il s'est vraiment le lancement de
cette de cette saison estivale et avec
toujours beaucoup d'audience télé
beaucoup de monde au bord du circuit
voilà donc c'est un événement qui
rassemble à l'aube des vacances d'été
alors pourquoi mantes-la-jolie et les
yvelines cette année alors pourquoi
mantes-la-jolie pourquoi les yvelines ça
s'est décidé dans l'hiver dernier alors
il faut savoir que les yvelines c'est
assez exceptionnel en fait un chantage
france dans les yvelines déjà en ile de
france le dernier remontait dans les
années 90 à montlhéry et les yvelines
il faut remonter très loin en arrière
je crois qu'aujourd'hui avec les jeux
olympiques qui seront là dans six ans
dans les yvelines
il ya un vrai engouement et des acteurs
locaux en fait pour accueillir des
événements d'envergure et voilà mantes
la jolie était il le département des
yvelines était ok pour accueillir cet
événement et se sont mis à pied d'oeuvre
pour le faire a dignement
est ce que la culture cyclisme des
yvelines a joué aussi dans le dossier de
candidature ait eu les championnats du
monde sur piste en 2015 au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il ya tous les ans depuis neuf ans paris
nice également qui passent dans les
yvelines
est ce que cette culture cycliste
finalement a fait pencher le dossier
ivy noir c'est sur les yvelines comme
vous venez de le signaler à creil des
des gros gros événement est de plus en
plus en fait avec le cyclisme avec le
vélodrome et 7
cet engouement pour les jeux dans
quelques années sûrement il ya également
la classique paris mantes qui est
vraiment connu en fait je pense par une
grande partie du peloton qui sera qui
sera au départ de cette épreuve lacunes
principe particulière au mois d'avril
chi chi chi chi difficile parce qu il ya
plein de petites côtes qui se succèdent
avec la présence du vent qui créent des
bordures est donc sacré des courses
ding ding deux grandes classiques et je
pense que ce sera un petit peu ce goût
là qu'on aura samedi dimanche sur les
championnats vous attendez combien de
personnes sur cet événement alors le
nombre de coureurs en fait c'est plus de
500 coureurs qui seront au départ de
chaque course et niveau du public j'ai
pas trop d'idée je me rends pas compte
ce que je sais c'est que les cautèles
seront remplies rempli de monde il à
70000 logements de plus il fera super
beau c'est vraiment un chiffre logique
mantes-la-jolie et accessible en plus on
a des coins vraiment sympa l'honneur de
demandes sur fond la ville et fontenay
saint père ou à vous ce sera très adapté
pour venir avec la glacière dès le matin
et a passé la journée à voir passer les
coureurs aient profité pour pique
alors c'est un événement très suivi sur
les routes mais également la télévision
à l'audience moyenne sur france
télévisions est de 1.5 million de
téléspectateurs pour l'épreuve hommes en
moyenne est de 750 mille spectateurs
pour les femmes c'est une compétition
vraiment passionnant c'est une
compétition qui passionne pendant un
mois en fait on a notamment les hommes
se sont se prépare pour le tour de
france
les filles ont également d'autres
épreuves internationales au mois de
juillet comme je disais c'est vraiment
un tournant important et donc ouais ça
attire énormément de monde à regarder
cette épreuve avant les grosses
échéances de l'été alors au niveau du
programme je le disais précédemment il
ya des épreuves en contre la montre et
des épreuves en ligne qui est ce qu'elle
est l'épreuve la plus attendue par le
public
je pense que ce sont les épreuves en
ligne qui sont les plus attendues celles
qui ont le plus d'audience
c'est là où on fait la plus de bagarres
même si les contre la montre
voilà en france on progresse beaucoup
dans la discipline on aura 70 coureurs
hommes autant de professionnels que des
amateurs donc déjà des amateurs qui vont
se confronter aux pros et une
quarantaine de féminines avec certaines
qui sont également professionnelle donc
ça c'est toute la journée
pardon tout l'après midi de jeudi il ya
un contre la montre qui est assez
difficile qui en deux parties donc je
pense que ça peut attirer déjà beaucoup
de monde dès le jeudi et les circuits de
la course en ligne samedi et dimanche
ils sont vraiment favorable à adé course
d'attaqué donc on peut avoir un
spectacle fantastique et parmi les têtes
d'affiché qui on retrouvera sur les
routes de montage mais celle et chez les
féminines
on attend de revoir un peu polignac a
passé beaucoup de temps à pauline
ferrand prévôt part donc à passer
beaucoup de temps sur le vtt je pense
pas que ce soit le circuit trop à son
avantage mais voilà elle aura à
détricoter un peu les les grosses
équipes qui sont de plus en plus
nombreuses
notamment l'une des plus nombreuses fdj
nouvelle aquitaine futuroscope
et puis chez les hommes alors on
pourrait citer les locaux allaient les
galopins les résas encore on accorde de
briller la fdj depuis quelques années
fait une mainmise sur le tableau sur le
maillot bleu blanc rouge
est ce que ce sera en eau de mer avec
une arrivée au sprint où un coureur plus
plus attaquant qui voudra l'emporter
voilà un peu les les affiches merci
beaucoup emmanuel brunet on souhaite de
bons championnats de france sur route et
jouera pour moi alors je vous rappelle
les dates quand même le rendez vous sont
organisés de ce jeudi à 28 juin au
dimanche 1er juillet à mantes la jolie
avant de se quitter du beau temps et de
la vigilance en prévision pour ce
week-end météo france a lancé un
bulletin d'alerté samedi dimanche et
lundi pour de fortes chaleurs le pic
devrait être atteint dans la journée de
dimanche des températures au delà des 30
degrés attendus et face à la montée du
mercure quelques conseils boire bien sûr
régulièrement de l'eau mais aussi penser
à s'alimenter convenablement éviter les
efforts physiques et maintenez votre
habitation au frais en fermant par
exemple les volets en cas de malaise
composer le 15
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi le replay est
disponible sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 belle
soirée à tous
[Musique]